This is the record-breaking Kickstarter-funded season 3 of 99% Invisible. Give yourself a round of applause. I'm Roman Mars. Newmatic. New? M-D-Q. Newmatic. Newmatic tubes of or pertaining to air guesses or when. Oh, good!
这是打破纪录、由 Kickstarter 资助的《99% Invisible》第三季。给自己鼓个掌吧。我是罗曼·马斯 (Roman Mars)。纽马蒂克。新？M-D-Q。纽马蒂克。气动传送信件或物品的或是与空气有关的。哦，太棒了！
You're here! Donnie, we found some tubes in the wall and now we're trying to see where the tubes go. You see, things go away and they never come back. How the heck does it work? I guess we'll never know. Back you. Yeah, right, vacuum. Let it rip.
你来了！唐尼，我们在墙里发现了一些管道，现在我们正试图看看这些管道通往哪里。你看，东西运走了就再也没有回来。这到底是怎么运作的？我想我们永远不会知道了。交回给你。没错，真空。开始吧。
MUSIC In the world before telephone and email, the task of transmitting information and moving material objects was essentially the same challenge. The way you sent someone a message was pretty much the same process as sending someone a package you had to send a piece of physical media through the post or on a ship. It was the telegraph that divided telling someone something, from giving someone something. But remember, everyday people didn't speak Morse code, so the message had to be deciphered written on a slip of paper, and then it was delivered to the recipient.
音乐 在电话和电子邮件出现之前，传输信息和移动物质对象的任务本质上是同一个挑战。你给某人发消息的方式和给某人寄包裹的过程几乎是一样的——你必须通过邮局或乘船发送一件实物载体。正是电报将“告诉某人某事”与“给某人某事”区分开来。但请记住，普通人不会说摩斯密码，所以消息必须被破译、写在一张纸条上，然后送达收件人手中。
To learn... ...ma... ...dip... ...trip... Even though you can probably guess already that electronic communication eventually killed most of the need for pneumatic tubes, you may not know that it was the telegraph itself that also put pneumatic tubes into widespread use. As telegrams blew up and the cost dropped in the volume rows, it became very difficult
去学习……妈……迪普……特里普……尽管你可能已经猜到，电子通信最终消除了对气动管道的大部分需求，但你可能不知道，正是电报本身才使得气动管道得到广泛使用。随着电报的激增、成本的下降以及业务量的增长，变得非常困难
to quickly deliver them to their destinations. And so what they needed to do was come up with another way to get messages across the city quickly. So if you can't send something with that new thing or electricity stuff, you have to figure out a way to do it old school, sending a message as a physical object. It's a last mile problem. Getting to an end customer or an end recipient can be the more difficult problem. And they came up with the post-Numatic or the pneumatic post as a means of doing that. That is Molly Wright-Steanson, researcher,
迅速将其送达目的地。因此，他们需要做的是想出另一种方法，让消息快速穿过城市。所以，如果你不能用那个新玩意儿或电力之类的东西发送东西，你就必须想出一个老派的方法，把消息当作一个实体对象发送。这是最后一公里问题。到达最终客户或最终收件人可能是最困难的问题。他们想出了气动邮政系统（post-Numatic 或 pneumatic post）作为实现这一目标的方法。那是莫莉·赖特-斯特安森（Molly Wright-Steanson），研究员、
PhD student, and aficionata of all things pneumatic tube. Numatic tubes are systems of subterranean urban postal services that delivered messages underneath cities all across the world in major financial centers. Those were the large scale implementations, but later on there are a number of smaller pneumatic tube systems more familiar to people today. Our producer Sam Greenspan spoke with Molly through a different series of tubes. So, it turns out Molly and I had similar experiences with pneumatic tubes growing up.
博士生，也是气动管道迷。气动管道是地下城市邮政服务系统，在世界各地主要金融中心的城市地下传递信件。这些是大规模的应用，但后来有许多更小、今天人们更熟悉的气动管道系统。我们的制作人萨姆·格林斯潘（Sam Greenspan）通过另一系列管道与莫莉进行了交谈。所以，原来莫莉和我小时候对气动管道有着相似的经历。
When I was a kid, we used to go to the bank down the street. And I remember going to the bank with my dad, we'd go to the drive-through and he'd put his deposit slip or whatever inside this plastic canister. My mom would unroll her window and she'd get the canister from this big air-making device. And she put in whatever checks she wanted to deposit. And then I would see it shoot up. Sucked up through this clear tube. Through this clear tube.
当我还是个孩子的时候，我们经常去街尽头的银行。我记得我和爸爸去银行，我们去汽车得来速（drive-through），他把存款单或其他东西放进这个塑料罐里。我妈妈摇下车窗，从这个产生强大气流的装置里拿出了这个罐子。她放进她想存入的任何支票。然后我看着它飞射出去。通过这根透明的管子被吸了进去。通过这根透明的管子。
And it would shoot across to the bank. And then the ladies in the bank. The teller is night put in some candy or a max box card. Lollipops for me and my brothers and dog biscuits for the dog. And send it over with my dad's receipt. Back by Enumatic 2. And it just seemed...
它会飞射到银行。然后银行里的女士们。柜员晚上会放进一些糖果或马克斯盒子卡。给我和哥哥们的棒棒糖，还有给狗狗的狗饼干。然后用我爸爸的收据把它送过来。通过气动管道返回。这似乎……
Just seemed really cool, it seemed kind of magic. And they also harkened back to another era. You may only know about pneumatic tubes in the context of a bank drive-through. But when they were invented, they really set the stage for what communication would look like over the next century. The pneumatic post first started in London in 1853,
真的觉得很酷，感觉有点神奇。它们也让人回想起另一个时代。你可能只在银行汽车得来速的语境下才知道气动管道。但当它们被发明时，它们确实为接下来一个世纪的通信面貌奠定了基础。气动邮政最早于1853年在伦敦开始，
but the technology transferred very quickly to other cities. Vienna, Marseille, Munich, Milan, Berlin, Philadelphia, New York, St. Louis, Buenos Aires, Australia. In fact, there were pneumatic post systems in every major financial city on every continent with the exception of Antarctica.
但这项技术很快转移到了其他城市。维也纳、马赛、慕尼黑、米兰、柏林、费城、纽约、圣路易斯、布宜诺斯艾利斯、澳大利亚。事实上，除了南极洲之外，各大洲的每个主要金融城市都有气动邮政系统。
Antarctica's always lag lacking, but nowhere were pneumatic tubes more extensive than in Paris. At the end of the 19th century, Baron Houseman had totally redone Paris's urban layout, putting in those big, iconic boulevards and circular plazas. And he also put in sewers. So not only did the sewer carry potable water, and eventually electrical cables, but it carried
南极洲总是落后，但没有哪里的气动管道比巴黎更庞大。19世纪末，奥斯曼男爵（Baron Haussmann）彻底重塑了巴黎的城市布局，修建了那些宏伟标志性的林荫大道和环形广场。他还修建了下水道。因此，下水道不仅输送饮用水以及后来的电缆，还输送
pneumatic tubes. And these tubes inside of tubes were a hit. My 1919 Paris was processing 12 million pieces of pneumatic post a year. In my 1945, there were 450 kilometers of pneumatic tubing lining Paris's underground, making it possible to get a handwritten note across Paris in less than two hours without even breaking us what. Here's how it works. You write something on some special stationery and close it in a special envelope, pay special postage, and you get it to your local to beast. That's what you call one of the people who sends pneumatic posts. To beast puts the envelope in a canister, and let me tell you about these canisters. At first, they just looked like soup cans, but over time they became more aerodynamic and began to resemble
气动管道。这些管道中的管道大受欢迎。1919年，巴黎每年处理1200万件气动邮件。到1945年，巴黎地下有450公里的气动管道，使得手写便条能够在不到两小时内送达巴黎各地，甚至不用费吹灰之力。以下是它的工作原理。你在一些特殊的信纸上写下内容，装进特殊的信封，支付特殊的邮资，然后把它交给你当地的送信员（to beast）。这就是那些发送气动邮件的人的称呼。送信员将信封放入罐中，让我来跟你说说这些罐子。起初，它们看起来就像汤罐，但随着时间的推移，它们变得更加流线型，开始类似于
little rockets. Anyway, the two beast rings an electric bell to alert the two beast on the receiving end that there's an incoming canister, and then, though, it's hurtling through Paris's underbelly so fast that the sending two beast could actually hear the canister arriving at its destination. The descriptions that I've read from the 19th century talk about the shock, the noise of the shock of the pneumatic post arriving. The only mechanism that could provide enough force would be steam. And so there were gigantic steam engines underneath the hotel they post, which was the central post office in Paris, and they would produce the compressed and verified air that would serve to push or pull the pneumatic tubes
小火箭。无论如何，送信员会按响电铃，提醒接收端的送信员有进站的罐子，然后，它以极快的速度穿过巴黎的腹地，以至于发送的送信员实际上可以听到罐子到达目的地的声音。我读过的19世纪的描述谈到了这种冲击，气动邮政到达时的冲击声。唯一能够提供足够动力的机制是蒸汽。因此，在巴黎中央邮局所在地——邮政酒店（Hôtel des Postes）下面有巨大的蒸汽机，它们产生压缩空气和稀薄空气，用于推动或拉动气动管道
through all of the kilometers and miles and miles of tubes that were underneath the streets. There were also even buildings that just simply existed to produce air for the tube services. The biggest pneumatic tube systems had problems that required some creative troubleshooting. Harris had an interesting mechanism in case there was a blockage.
穿过街道底下的数公里和数英里长的管道。甚至还有一些建筑纯粹是为了给管网服务生产空气而存在的。最大的气动管道系统存在一些需要创造性故障排除的问题。巴黎有一个有趣的机制来应对堵塞。
Someone would fire a gun into the tube and then measure the sound waves and be able to figure out two within, I guess, two meters or so where the blockage was. And then they would be able to figure out two within, I guess, two meters or so, where the blockage was. And then they would be able to go underground and undo the flange and bring out the offending canister. I guess it's better than what happened in Berlin where they just poured copious amounts of wine into the tubes in order to unfreeze the stock canisters. As exciting as all this sounds, electric communication evolved.
有人会向管子里开枪，然后测量声波，从而能够找出——我猜——在两米左右的范围内堵塞在哪里。然后他们就能找出——我猜——在两米左右的范围内堵塞在哪里。然后他们就可以下到地下，拧开法兰，取出惹事的罐子。我想这比柏林发生的事情要好，在柏林，他们只是把大量的酒倒入管子里，以便解冻卡住的罐子。尽管听起来很刺激，但电子通信发展了。
Europe, other technologies like telephone and telefacts improved and got way cheaper. And so of the last mile problem. But it was another form of physical transport that put the nail in the coffin. The thing that put them out of business in the United States was the invention of the truck. The truck was invented in 1912 and that's kind of what did it. Trucks are fine at all, but they just don't capture the imagination like a massive pneumatic tube network as silly as such a thing might seem today. Molly and I spent a good deal of time trying to figure out what exactly it is about the
在欧洲，电话和传真等其他技术得到了改进，变得便宜得多。因此解决了最后一公里问题。但另一种实体运输方式给了它致命一击。在美国，让它们停业的是卡车的发明。卡车于1912年被发明，这基本上就是原因所在。卡车当然很好，但它们就是无法像庞大的气动管道网络那样激起人们的想象力，尽管今天看来这种东西可能很傻。我和莫莉花了很多时间试图弄清楚到底是什么
tubes that leads us to be fascinated with them. I have a couple of theories about why pneumatic tubes are magic. I think they inspire wonder because they're alive, or it feels like they're alive. They're reaching out through the city. They have tendrils and tentacles, and they breathe, and they throw things up, and they feel much, much bigger than we are. I also think they inspire wonder because
促使我们对管道着迷。我对于为什么气动管道具有魔力有几个理论。我认为它们能激发人们的惊叹，因为它们是活的，或者感觉它们是活的。它们在城市中延伸。它们有卷须和触手，它们在呼吸，它们吐出东西，它们感觉比我们大得多、大得多。我也认为它们能激发惊叹，因为
they manifest communication. You know, for us today, when we think of communication, all the ones and zeros and digital things that we move don't feel real tangible to us anymore. But I also think that they felt pretty magical to people back then too, that they were kind of electrical and breathing connections of communication. You could send a hankerchief and send it to your lover by a pneumatic tube, and it would still smell like you. So I mean, I think they were romantic as well, and I think that that's part of the winter today too. So in a sense they're both live and mechanical, both high and low tech and there's also something to be said about the journey of a tube canister that you can imagine it's snaking its way
它们具象化了通信。你知道，对我们今天来说，当我们想到通信时，我们移动的所有1和0以及数字化的东西对我们来说不再有实体感。但我也认为，在当时对人们来说它们也相当神奇，它们是某种电气化且会呼吸的通信连接。你可以通过气动管道寄送一块手帕给你的爱人，它依然会有你的气味。所以我的意思是，我认为它们也是浪漫的，我认为这也是当今魅力的一部分。所以在某种意义上，它们既是活的又是机械的，既是高科技又是低技术的，关于管子罐的旅程也有话要说，你可以想象它像蛇一样蜿蜒穿过
through these underground passageways carrying your message. And so this idea of being able to go somewhere where you wouldn't otherwise be able to go is amazing. That tube message has made that entire underworld journey in order to surface in the hands of its recipient. More than their widespread use, what might be the most surprising thing about pneumatic tube systems is how long they stayed in use. The post-Numatique operated in Paris until as late as 1964, tubes even ran over the Brooklyn
这些地下通道，运送着你的信息。因此，这种能够去到你平时无法到达的地方的想法是惊人的。那个管子里的信息完成了整个地下世界的旅程，最终浮现在收件人的手中。除了它们的广泛使用之外，关于气动系统最令人惊讶的可能是它们维持使用的时间之长。巴黎的气动邮政一直运行到1964年，管道甚至在布鲁克林
Bridge until 1953. And it took a force of nature to knock them out of Prague, that city was using them until a flood in 2002. But get this, lots of places still use pneumatic tubes. Hospitals use pneumatic tube systems, and that's because you really can't digitize tissue or medication. And so the next time you find yourself in a hospital, take a look because you'll find them by the nurse's stations and in the emergency room. They're also used at places at grocery stores or big electronics stores, usually that kind
大桥上运行到1953年。而且需要一股自然力量才能将它们从布拉格清除，该市一直使用它们直到2002年的洪水。但你得知道，很多地方现在仍在使用气动管道。医院使用气动管道系统，这是因为你真的无法将组织或药物数字化。所以下次你置身于医院时，看一看，因为你会在护士站和急诊室找到它们。它们也被用于杂货店或大型电子产品商店等地方，通常是那种
of delivery of all of the money through pneumatic tubes so that it's not anywhere where the store could get robbed. When Molly was doing research on tubes at the New York City Public Library, she found that her requests were being dispatched via pneumatic tube. But there's one other tube system in New York that moves a lot more material.
通过气动管道传输所有的现金，这样就不会放在商店容易被抢劫的地方。当莫莉在纽约公共图书馆研究管道时，她发现她的索书请求是通过气动管道发送的。但纽约还有另一个管网传输更多的材料。
In Roosevelt Island, pneumatic tubes are used for garbage. Roosevelt Island, if you don't know, is a small island in the east river between Manhattan and Queens in New York. And as it happens, my good friend Hannah Jamal grew up there. Hey. Hey, Hannah, how's it going? Good, nice to hear from you.
在罗斯福岛，气动管道用于处理垃圾。如果你不知道的话，罗斯福岛是纽约曼哈顿和皇后区之间东河中的一个小岛。碰巧的是，我的好朋友汉娜·贾马尔（Hannah Jamal）在那里长大。嘿。嘿，汉娜，最近怎么样？很好，很高兴听到你的声音。
So I called up Hannah and asked her about the pneumatic tubes in her hometown. I get frustrated when people ask me about the garbage tubes because to me, how you take out your trash on those both island is not the most fascinating thing about it. Yes I'm sure that there are thousands of fascinating facts about Roosevelt Island but let's hear about those garbage tubes. Yeah so Roosevelt Island is only about three miles long and about 800 feet wide and when the island was being developed for residential living in the 1960s planners determined that the quality of life would be better without big garbage trucks on the roads. I know, right?
所以我打电话给汉娜，问她关于她家乡气动管道的事。每当人们问我关于垃圾管道的事时，我都感到沮丧，因为对我来说，罗斯福岛处理垃圾的方式并不是那里最迷人的事情。是的，我确信罗斯福岛有成千上万个迷人的事实，但让我们听听关于那些垃圾管道的事吧。是的，所以罗斯福岛只有大约三英里长，大约800英尺宽，当这个岛在20世纪60年代被开发用于住宅居住时，规划人员确定，没有大卡车在路上行驶的生活质量会更好。我懂，对吧？
So instead, they dispatched with their trash with a pneumatic tube network. And I have one friend in particular, and he's my friend, David, and he can tell you more about how it works. So I asked Brooklyn-based producer, Mouge Zadi, to go meet Hannah's friend. Oh, hey, how's it going Moog?
所以相反，他们用气动管道网络处理垃圾。我有一个特别的朋友，他是我的朋友大卫，他可以告诉你更多关于它是如何运作的。所以我请驻布鲁克林的制作人穆格·扎迪（Moog Zadi）去见汉娜的朋友。哦，嘿，穆格，最近怎么样？
Nice to meet you. The guy named David Kimble Stanley, and I live in Roseville, D'Iland. Well, tell me when you want to start talking about the trash, because there isn't that much to say about it. That's what's sort of fine about all this. But here, okay. The beginning of the process is I guess the same as what most people deal with. It's just like taking out the trash.
很高兴见到你。这个人叫大卫·金布尔·斯坦利（David Kimble Stanley），我住在罗斯福岛。好吧，告诉我你想什么时候开始谈论垃圾，因为关于它其实没什么好说的。这正是这一切巧妙的地方。但这里，好吧。这个过程的开始我猜和大多数人处理的差不多。就像倒垃圾一样。
You take your trash bags and then... The process is I guess the same as what most people deal with. It's just like taking out the trash. You take your trash bags and then... Just take out a plastic bag and we tie it up. And then we go outside here, come with me. You walk out into the hallway? We go out into the hallway. And just on each floor there's a room which is called the A-Vac room. And I've lived in Roosevelt Island my whole life.
你拿着垃圾袋然后……这个过程我猜和大多数人处理的差不多。就像倒垃圾一样。你拿着垃圾袋然后……只需拿出一个塑料袋，我们把它扎好。然后我们去外面这里，跟我来。你走到走廊里？我们走到走廊里。每个楼层都有一个房间，叫做 A-Vac 房间。我在罗斯福岛住了我的一生。
It's the same thing and at least all the original buildings. And I imagine it's the same in the newer buildings. But basically every floor has a trash room. ours is right next to the stairwell. You open it up and there's not a lot in it. It's just a tiny little closet like space and there's a place for recyclables but recyclables, that stuff that that is recyclables, is put in this big shoe. With a little candle that you pull and you pull up in the door and show your garbage down the street and that's it. And that's it.
所有原汁原味的建筑里都是一样的。我想较新的建筑里也是一样的。但基本上每层楼都有一个垃圾房。我们的就在楼梯间旁边。你打开它，里面没有多少东西。它只是一个像小壁橱一样的空间，里面有一个放置可回收物的地方，但是可回收物，那些可回收的东西，是被放进这个大滑槽里的。拉动一个小拉手，你把门往上一拉，把垃圾扔下去，就是这样。就是这样。
To be honest, like it wasn't until after I left Roseville, Thailand that I realized that other people don't have a vacuum, so that's not the system that's used. I try to remember precisely when I learned about it, and I think it might have been a Wikipedia. I like double-check that I knew at pneumatic men. It's like, oh, so it just sucks the trash, that's amazing. And then I, yeah, went on with my day. In fairness, the tubes might have made a bigger impression if Hannah and David had to put
老实说，直到我离开罗斯福岛后，我才意识到其他人没有真空系统，这不是人们使用的系统。我试着回想我是什么时候精确了解到它的，我想可能是在维基百科上。我喜欢仔细检查我知道气动（pneumatic）是什么意思。就像，哦，所以它只是吸走垃圾，这太神奇了。然后我，是的，继续我的一天。公平地说，如果汉娜和大卫必须把
their trash bag in a rocket ship ship canister and fire it across the island, but there's still something about a visit to Roosevelt Island that makes you feel like you're on the cusp of the future, even though you're clearly not. Hey, Monley, can I try a theory? Sure. Okay, if you think about all the technology we were promised the future would hold. From something like Star Trek. A lot of it has come true, right?
他们的垃圾袋放进火箭舰罐子里并将其射过整个岛屿，这些管道可能会留下更深刻的印象，但参观罗斯福岛仍然有些东西让你觉得你正处于未来的前沿，尽管你显然不是。嘿，莫莉，我能试着提出一个理论吗？当然。好吧，如果你想想我们被承诺未来将拥有的所有技术。比如《星际迷航》里的东西。很多都实现了，对吧？
Like we have little touchscreen computers, we have hand communicators. But one of the things that we don't have, and we'll probably never have, is the transporter, you know, the thing that can disassemble something somewhere, and reassemble it somewhere else. And I wonder if that has to do with why the tubes feel both so ancient and so futuristic at the same time. Like it's the closest we ever got to transmitting a physical object instantaneously. I think that's possible. I think that's definitely possible that you could get something instantly or that it's
比如我们有微型触屏电脑，我们有手持通信器。但我们没有的、而且可能永远不会有的东西之一就是传送器，你知道的，那个可以在某个地方解体某物并在其他地方重新组装的东西。我在想这是否与为什么管道感觉既古老又充满未来感有关。就像这是我们离瞬间传输物理对象最近的一次。我认为这是可能的。我认为这绝对是可能的，你可以立即得到某物，或者它
again that you could communicate instantly, that you could not only get it, but you could have that feeling and that sensation or that information right away. It's the nexus of those two things. But it's more than just information. The scented handkerchief that arrives after traveling through miles of Paris underground or even the dog biscuit from the bank to where these are romantic because they have physical intimacy. I mean maybe that's why we keep coming back to it and maybe that's why
再次说明你可以瞬间沟通，你不仅能得到它，还能立即拥有那种感觉和那种信息。这是这两者的结合。但这不仅仅是信息。在穿过巴黎地下数英里后到达带有香味的手帕，甚至是银行给的狗饼干，这些都很浪漫，因为它们具有身体上的亲密感。我的意思是，也许这就是我们不断回溯的原因，也许这就是为什么
steampunk seems important in a digital age that actually we do need physical things and you know we we never did get our jet packs, but we do care all the more about things that are real and tangible that come to us. And I think with the pneumatic post represents ties, what pneumatic tubes represent to us, is the possibility that that could happen. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Sam Greenspan and me Roman Mars with help from Moog Zating. It's a project of KALW 91.7 local public radio in San Francisco and the American Institute of Architects in San Francisco and the American Institute of Architects in San Francisco.
蒸汽朋克在数字时代显得如此重要，实际上我们确实需要实体的东西，你知道的，我们从来没有得到喷气背包，但我们确实更加关心那些真实、有形、来到我们身边的事物。我认为气动邮政所代表的、气动管道对我们而言所代表的，是这一切可能发生的可能性。《99% Invisible》本周由萨姆·格林斯潘和我和罗曼·马斯制作，莫格·扎迪提供了帮助。这是旧金山本地公共广播电台 KALW 91.7 以及旧金山美国建筑师学会（American Institute of Architects in San Francisco）的一个项目。
You can find this show and like the show on Facebook, all of us are on Twitter, Instagram, and Spotify, but to find out more about this story including cool pictures and links and listen to all the episodes of 99% Invisible. You must go to 99pi.org. Radio to the end. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在 Facebook 上找到并关注这个节目，我们都在 Twitter、Instagram 和 Spotify 上，但要了解有关这个故事的更多信息，包括酷炫的照片和链接，并收听《99% Invisible》的所有剧集，你必须访问 99pi.org。电台播放直到最后。来自 PRX。本集尚无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。